make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob we are
picking back up again with Batman and I
know it's been a little while since we
covered this has been quite some time
since we covered the Batman comics right
but like we need to get caught out right
because there's some cool stuff coming
down the pipe so those of you guys who
are playing catch-up
of course you'll find the link to the
previous video down in the description
so you can watch that and find out
everything that's going on but
effectively what's happening here is
James Tinian kind of kicked things off
with his run on Batman following Tom
King and he introduced a character
called the designer and we didn't really
know anything about him right and
there's been several videos across
YouTube that a focus on the origin of
the character but the designer was
basically a guy who seemingly went to a
handful of criminals in Gotham City and
then basically said like that will help
you guys achieve the goal of effectively
taking the city over for yourself and
this seemed to happen a number of years
ago and so the implication was that a
lot of the schemes and things that were
going on in the city of Gotham with
regards to the criminals we're all based
on the efforts of the designer himself
and and what this basically did is it
led to the idea that the designer seems
to have returned and Batman has kind of
caught up in this whole thing again it's
kind of interesting because it invokes
like Deathstroke and it evokes a few
other characters here and there but we
basically left off with the idea the
Deathstroke's assassins more or less his
henchmen for lack of a better word I had
basically been taken and then you end up
picking up with Harley Quinn who's
basically controlling a bunch of these
these weapons belonging to Batman and
assuming them after Deathstroke right so
this part of the story kind of kicks off
you know it picks up with a bang
and it's kind of a cool thing because
what it does is it switches back over to
Catwoman and to Bruce Wayne now one of
the things that James Tinian kept going
after the events of Tom King was the
relationship between Catwoman and Bruce
Wayne and a lot of people really like
this right it just kind of made sense
one of the things that always kind of
threw me off about Tom Kings riding was
the way that Batman and Catwoman talked
to each other
just never really seemed organic James
Kenan really seems to correct that right
Tom Kings riding was a little weird but
James tinning really seems to correct
that and basically giving us this
seemingly organic conversation between
the two but because of the fact that
Catwoman was one of the initial
individuals who dealt with the designer
she's the one that basically has all
this information and the response of
Batman is I need you to tell me
everything that's going on and so what
this does is it gives us a kind of
flashback with the origin of the
designer himself and so far as it's
given to us here and what we basically
learn is that at some point in the past
seemingly around 20 years ago so you
know seems to be the indication the
Catwoman was basically just a kind of
burglar right she was in her in the
early days of her career
but there was a kind of legend of a guy
named the designer this this individual
out there that was responsible for
pulling off some of the greatest heists
that ever happened it's cool here
because he was almost kind of like this
mythical enigmatic figure right he
existed but it's one of these things
where people were just kind of like this
guy's more myth than actual fact and so
what ended up happening is that there
was basically a card sent to Catwoman
that was essentially an invitation from
the designer to meet at a particular
location and when she arrives there
she's met by the Riddler she's met by
Joker and she's met by penguin all of
whom have been invited as well and
they're seemingly brought in by this guy
on a boat which is kind of creepy in
terms of how he looks it's almost like
crossing the river Styx right where like
you have to pay the coins to the guy on
the boat what his name is he has an
actual name in a Greek and Roman Roman
theology but but nonetheless they're
they're basically brought to this house
right it's called the house of Tartarus
would they meet with the designer for
the very first time and it's kind of
nuts here because the designer sort of
pops up in and really says like way he's
talking to the Joker he's like you're
the conference of crime like your
reputation precedes you the indication
here is that the designer knows
everything about these guys and when
they are brought here their weapons are
basically handed over to make sure that
nothing pops off but it's kind of a cool
thing the other cool thing about this is
the designer looks amazing right in
terms of his design he looks absolutely
awesome but it's kind of a cool thing
because what we also end up learning is
that with this guy here with the
designer in his past he had basically
come across a kind of detective and
there is more to this story but we'll
figure out you know what that is later
on down the line but this designer had
basically faced off against this
detective and ultimately found what we
basically see with Batman comics all the
time that the villain fights the good
guy and the good guy always wins because
a good guys always one or two steps
ahead the designer kind of found himself
in this constant struggle of always
losing because the detective he was
finding was just that much more
intelligent that he was and he came to
the realization that in order to win he
has to out think the detective more so
than that it can't just be a plan the
detective doesn't expect he has to be so
far ahead did by the time the detective
realizes there's no chance for him to
win he's already lost and ultimately the
designer ended up spending a year inside
of his own facility at his own kind of
base of operations for lack of a better
word and just kept coming up with all
these ideas and all these plans that
were so advanced and so nuanced the
detective never saw them coming and the
only real indication we get here is that
the detective was not actually killed by
the designer and said he was left
essentially
disgraced right he was left its grace
and and for the most part the world
seems to have lost faith in him and
ultimately he just ended up dying
seemingly of old age but it ended up
dying you know realizing that he was
defeated by what seemed to be either his
greatest foe or any one of the many foes
and he faced off against but the
designer proved to be successful in that
regard and so what it does is it
basically allows the designer to tell
the the various people these various
villains this story and then say I can
help all of you achieve your goal now
it's interesting the way the Tinian
writes this because the villains really
just kind of seem to go along with it
right I mean the reputation of the
designer really seems to kind of
solidify that he's a guy that deserves
to be believed but there's no guarantee
that his reputation is really accurate
outside of the various rumors and
hearsay that the villains have heard and
so it is kind of left to assume that the
designer is is actually correct right he
can do this stuff because his reputation
is such that the individuals who are
telling the story are beyond
contestation as far as these various
villains are concerned but it is a
pretty cool concept here and so with
Catwoman and with the Riddler and with
penguin meeting with the designer in
turn they all kind of come out really a
lot happier than they were going in
because there seems to be truth to the
idea that the designer can help them
achieve their goals now the whole reason
behind this is the designer can get rich
right he's like I'm gonna help all of
you achieve your goals but I want half
of all your earnings but I want half of
everything you take and then we'll just
you know you'll never hear from me again
and so finally the designer meets with
the Joker and as we know the Joker is
really kind of a wild card you never
really know what's going to happen and
so somehow we don't really know what was
said but the result was that when the
Joker had his conversation with the
designer the designer immediately comes
out and it's just like kill them all so
whenever the Joker said piss this guy
off nice and good not only that with
everything popping off right like all
these with all these forces of the
designer coming after all the various
villains who were here the Joker ends up
revealing that he still has a gun that
he kept hidden and he shoots the
designer in the head and that seems to
be the end of him not only that the
various henchmen of the designer are
taken out the Joker seemingly killed
everybody here it is kind of nuts
because it's like what in the world
could the Joker have possibly said to
this guy that would have led to this
becoming what it was not only that you
also end up having the villains here
saying okay then we're gonna sweep this
under the rug this is gonna be our dirty
little secret and that's kind of the
secret they were referencing in the
video that we that we did last time
right they all kind of share this this
mutual secret we didn't really know how
deep it went but basically the designer
was the guy who was gonna help them
achieve their goals and none of their
goal
could be achieved without the funding of
the designer which really seemed to be
kind of the plan right like I'll tell
you how you can achieve your goal but
it's all for naught if you don't have
the financial backing to do it like the
money to be able to pull it off and so
they have these plans with no means to
achieve them and so they end up kind of
sweeping the whole thing under the rug
but for the Joker himself where they
burn Tartarus house and just kind of
leave it there the Joker is kind of
staring off in the distance and that's
when Catwoman comments that she began to
realize how evil the Joker is going to
become because the Joker basically knows
what his plan is he knows what he can do
and the Joker could essentially find a
way to bypass the finances needed by the
designer and then in turn pull it off on
his own anyway not only that when
Catwoman finishes this conversation with
Batman Batman comes to the realization
that the plan of Catwoman was to
basically rob him her plan was to rob
Bruce Wayne and so if the designer could
help her achieve that goal then the
designer knew that Batman is Bruce Wayne
not only that the designer knows how to
access his family's wealth meaning
Batman could seemingly lose everything
and so what it does is it switches over
to the Joker and you know basically in
the modern day talking to a bartender
you know essentially drinking what looks
like looks like a margarita but he kind
of starts telling the story from his
perspective and basically says that
during this meeting they had with the
designer that the designer basically
said I can help you guys achieve these
various goals right and so ultimately he
said like each of you guys will get a
boon you'll basically get some kind of
financial backing so on and so forth and
so ultimately the the penguin wanted to
be king of Gotham City right he wanted
to be the mayor he want to be the one to
run the show the Riddler wanted to be
the smartest person in Gotham City and
Catwoman wanted to be the wealthiest but
with Joker sitting down and looking at
this and realizing that there would be
no room for the designer in Gotham City
itself
The Joker came to the realization that
what the designer intended to do was
help them achieve their goals and then
with nobody else there take them all out
and then seemingly be the only one to
conquer Gotham City or the indication is
that Joker was the one who wanted to do
that but basically what he told the
designer is if you're the devil then I
want to take your place I want to kill
you and I want to be the one to conquer
Gotham City and that seems to have been
the reason why the designer kind of
freaked out because the Joker was the
one this seemed to pick up on what it
was it was actually happening again this
is Joker in the and the way he tells his
stories are oftentimes ambiguous in the
sense that we don't know if they're ever
true we don't know if he's ever really
telling the truth but again what it does
is it basically picks up with
Deathstroke and Batman
oh no Batman hot on his trail the fact
that Harley Quinn is basically kind of
blowing through all the various devices
of Batman and Batman is I'm chiming into
Lucius Fox and saying like shut down her
control of these things she's basically
spending money like water through a
sieve that's not okay
that's the problem Bruce Wayne
ultimately manages to track down
Deathstroke and of course he ends up
taking him captive or at least you know
Deathstroke jumps on to onto the batwing
and then just starts like attacking it
and so on and so forth one thing that
does happen here is cat woman ends up
locating Harley Quinn and then the two
of them basically leave for track down
the designer or something along those
lines they're met by a couple of Joker
eyes members from the Gotham City Police
Department this kind of seems to be
partially a scheme of the Joker we're
not entirely sure here but what it does
is it allows a kind of battle between
Batman and Deathstroke now the reality
is that this has kind of been done to
death right Batman versus Deathstroke
but what makes this interesting is the
conversation between the two because
what you end up having here is
Deathstroke and that and really having
this conversation where Batman kind of
looks around and says like down there in
Gotham City there's 9 million people and
ironically enough their faith in their
government actually went up when Bane
took control it's one of these
interesting things we talked about that
in the city of Bane story or like people
would say Gallo is terrible that Bane
took over Gotham and all that kind of
stuff but at the end according to the
people there
he made the city a better place that
Batman's not really willing to do what
it takes in order to actually win this
battle that's the interesting thing
about the Batman mythos is I hear people
kind of create these arguments all the
time of like well if that were the logic
then like Superman should kill his
villains and the spider managed to kill
his villains and so on and so forth but
Batman categorically and unequivocally
has the worst most violent rogues
gallery in all of comic books and that's
why there's a legitimate case to make
there and saying that Batman should kill
all his villains right because the city
of Gotham would be better off with all
those various villains dead it's cool
because that made kind of looks at this
and says yeah like this city is the way
it is because of me and it's one of
these things where he almost kind of
tries to play it based on like well you
know my parents died when I was a little
kid they were shot in alley and I was I
had to go down this path and all this
kind of stuff and Deathstroke's not
buying and he's like at the end of the
day man you can you can calm me whatever
story you want you but you escalated
we were criminals doing criminal things
you're the one who donned a cloak and
cowl and then you're the one that
started taking us out the way that you
did we had to step up because you
stepped up you're sort of left asking
the question right if Bruce Wayne
becoming Batman is what led to criminals
becoming more violent
then is Batman really the reason why
Gotham is the way it is where criminals
ever going to become that vet violent in
the first place or did they only ever
really get that way because of Batman
it's interesting to look at it for the
other steel from the other side of the
equation and so Batman tries to reason
with Deathstroke and it's like look I'm
trying to change the fact that I've
gotten extreme in recent years because
he has Batman's become more and more
extreme as comics have gone on you look
at like the Silver Age Batman and then
you compare him to like Batman from like
Infinite Crisis Final Crisis the new 52
Batman's be gotten more and more extreme
over the years because remember it's all
just one cohesive continuity now right
so Batman has has gotten more extreme
over the years and worries like I'm
trying to change this extreme nature but
what I need you guys to do is to
basically slow down and stop the
response of Deathstroke is no that's not
gonna happen right like we're not going
to slow down we're not going to stop and
so Batman basically like just lunges at
him and sends the both of them flying
off the batwing and ultimately
Deathstroke calls his bluff right he's
like look man you can do this all day
long if you want to but we both know
you're gonna shoot one of your back
grappling guns right so just do that do
the damn thing and then save us right
and that's exactly what he does right he
shoots a grappling hook and basically
ends up saving him and Deathstroke and
that's essentially yet and it's kind of
a funny thing because Deathstroke can
essentially play Batman like a fiddle
Batman's predictable there's just a line
that Batman won't cross and because the
villains know Batman won't cross that
line at the end of the day he's always
only ever a half-measure because it's
kind of like I won't do what needs to be
done in order to save Gotham City
because I don't believe in killing but
my parents were killed and you know
yadda yadda yadda and and so on and so
forth but sometimes it's in the best
interest to kill a villain right is it's
in the in the interest of people by
Batman not killing his villains all he's
doing is sacrificing innocent lives what
he's saying like the thousands of people
that that that that Joker's going to
kill over the course of a year or
several years or something like that
they are not as valuable is the Joker's
life right the Joker being redeemed is
more valuable than those innocent people
and that's why it's always an
interesting question how many lives is
Batman willing to sacrifice before he
says enough is enough because in the end
if he has the means to kill the Joker
but he doesn't he is in effect
sacrificing those people's lives and so
where the designer finally pops up to
Batman
and basically says you know Deathstroke
you're done now indicating to
Deathstroke that he's gonna get screwed
over on his contract Batman's kind of
like you don't come and face me and the
response the designer is no we still
have one more game left and that's when
Edward nygma the Riddler pops up and
says
the entirety of Gotham City is now under
my control I've split the entire city
into what's basically a giant crossword
puzzle and there's these enormous walls
as tall as buildings you know and it's
like everybody stay put where you are
the only way the entire city is going to
be let loose is if Batman's able to
correctly solve this crossword puzzle if
he guesses wrong then I basically blow
up a bomb right in the indication here
is that if he guesses like three across
and like four down and he gets it wrong
that section gets destroyed with a bomb
and so lives our lives are basically in
jeopardy here this is the kind of thing
I'm talking about right like this
wouldn't be a problem if Edward nygma
we're dead and so it's it's it's kind of
interesting because ultimately Lucius
Fox cannot really locate wherever enigma
is where the Riddler is and nygma just
starts cutting off Batman's
communications in order to force him in
a situation where he has to use his own
wits in order to be able to pull this
off and it's kind of cool because this
is an insane amount of hubris on behalf
of the Riddler because we're this kind
of starts going down
Batman ends up of course taking taking
Deathstroke who's currently handcuffed
and then takes him to like a Batman
train literally Batman has a bat train
and so while that's happening while
Batman is facing off against these these
forces of of the designer who are
seemingly kind of coming out of nowhere
and waiting on this train to arrive and
then you end up having Riddler who's
asking these questions right one across
nine spaces the more I take the more I
leave behind
Batman's response footsteps Joker comes
in eight down five spaces
what has many keys but can open no doors
Batman's response to piano he's
answering all these things like that
right just off the top of his head and
this is James tennen really showing the
intelligence of Bruce Wayne this is one
of the most important aspects and is one
of the coolest things right because like
when you look at Snyder's Batman run
what mate what really showcased Bruce
Wayne's intelligence was the small
things right now some of that was
because it's Batman Comics Batman can't
die because you know he's just too
popular for DC to kill off he just sells
too well right and so that's why Batman
always comes out on top but to see a
display of his intelligence like this
just constantly countering Edward
numerous questions every every time he
asked a scenario Batman basically
answers almost perfectly right 10 across
11 spaces a woman shoots her husband
holds him underwater for five minutes
hangs him and then takes him out to
dinner how was that possible the
response of Batman photography
she took a picture of him but being able
to like counter every single one of
edward nygma's riddles also top
his head with the greatest of ease
despite being completely battle-worn and
totally exhausted shows how far above
Edward nigma Batman really is and that's
where nygma starts getting pissed off
and that was always his weakness but in
comics that was always a weakness of
Edward nygma he would let his temper get
the better of him if Batman started
getting the better of him it was just
kind of a it was it was always the thing
that ended up catching him off-guard now
from here this picks up with Catwoman
and Harley Quinn and a pretty
interesting scenario right we end up
finding out what it is that Harley Quinn
and Catwoman are actually up to and in
reality it's just Catwoman Harley
Quinn's just kind of along for the ride
but we end up finding out there what
Catwoman is looking for is someone
called the under broker and this is an
individual who basically has access to
essentially every bank account across
the entirety of Gotham City you can you
can access anybody's account using the
help of this particular guy now Catwoman
says that she has the account numbers
that she's a member of their club and
good standing and this basically leads
to Catwoman being allowed in by the
under broker himself the issue with this
is that as Catwoman gets in there
they're met by the arrival of punchline
the punchline is actually there not only
that this is when Harley Quinn meets The
Joker's new girlfriend for the very
first time and it is cool because Harley
Quinn doesn't initially know that
instead it just kind of like pumps lines
like I'm here to make a withdrawal - I'm
the punchline I'm where you end it's
kind of a lame phrase to have but it is
a cool thing to see them encounter each
other because when when Harley Quinn's
like who in the world is this person
Catwoman is like she's the Joker's new
girlfriend and Harley's like oh this
girl's in for a ton you would think
Holly Clin would be pissed about being
replaced right like oh no no let me tell
you some Harley Quinn is often imitated
never duplicated that's not the response
right that's not what happens instead
Holly's kinda like okay so like you're
in for a rough ride like I know it seems
cool to be the Joker's new girlfriend at
the moment he's gonna screw you up in
ways that you can't even begin to
imagine yet not only that Harley's whole
thing is like are you funny cuz you
don't really sound funny and like
punchline tries to make a few sort of
veiled threats and outright threats and
tries to make a few jokes here and there
but at the end of the day Holly's not
buying it if she's like I've been around
this block more than a few times you got
nothing you got nothing no jokes no puns
no anything you are a poor man's Harley
Quinn and then she basically tells her
like in a few years and a few dozen
cries in the shower and so
so forth I'm gonna buy you a frozen
margarita and we're gonna have a girly
girl chat about how you made the worst
decision of your life but until then I'm
gonna bash your head in with a hammer
and immediately attacks the girl I love
that not only that of course Catwoman
ends up getting your hand on the under
broker and then we end up finding out
you know who this guy is right that his
name is Harlan graves this guy has all
kinds of information but Catwoman knows
everything about him as well and so it's
like if you if you don't tell me what I
want to know I'm gonna start spewing all
your private information for Harley
Quinn and for punchline to here and if
you don't want me to do that you're
gonna take me to a computer terminal to
get me where I need to go the reality
what seems to be going on here is that
if the designer does have the plan of
Catwoman which was to rob Bruce Wayne
and seemingly his sim punchline for that
purpose to access that computer terminal
and of course Catwoman is there to
basically withdraw those funds or to
move those funds to a different location
so the designer can't get his hands on
right so Bruce Wayne doesn't lose
everything and so with that being the
case Batman ends up tracking down the
Riddler after we recognize his word as
the Riddler's at he takes out the
Riddler right it's not a great big huge
thing Riddler's not really physically
capable in comparison to Batman the
Riddler's taken out pretty quickly
Batman basically knocks out Deathstroke
with a tranquilizer dart there's enough
to keep an elephant of asleep for a few
hours so on Deathstroke it'll probably
work for like half an hour 45 minutes
you know because of his healing factor
and so Batman is basically kind of met
by the arrival of the designer who says
you know it's cool you've unravel all
your adversaries designs that's awesome
but it's not gonna be enough because you
must know that if I'm in Bruce Wayne's
office then it means I must know who you
are and the designer confirms that and
saying hello Bruce Wayne it's time that
you and I have a conversation before I
kill you
well that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explained make
sure you guys with the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]